a New Jersey high school upsetting
students and some parents after
implementing a new policy to make the
cheerleading team more inclusive the
school saying the squad must now accept
everyone or be disbanded this decision
coming after one parent complained when
her child didn't make the cut following
tryouts last month so Greg is this a
case of you know he was a cheater right
yes I was is that right yes yeah no Greg
was a cheerleader having fun in his
extreme America so do you think this is
weakening our children I am I am I don't
know here's my feeling it's a small
local story over a beef over a
cheerleading choice some parent got
ticked off now it's a national story I'm
a little scared none of the teachers or
coaches make enough money to be forced
to deal with a transient spotlight
seeking the latest raw meat that's what
I feel I guess I feel ambivalent is that
I know I'm not supposed to this is a
terrible story this is political
correctness run amok that you wanted
that's why just percolating below the
surface so there were five hopefuls Dana
who didn't make it because they didn't
score 87 or higher they sweat they did
score 78 to 86
so this the school said you know what
you guys can participate okay so I'm not
outraged because it takes a lot to get
me outraged but I will say this they are
not doing them any favors for when
they're gonna enter the job market and
it's a super competitive world right now
for to get a job and guess what
twenty people don't get the job one
person will get the job so that was a
good point
powerful does come as a cheerleader
former cheerleader yes I agree so Jessie
what about positive reinforcement you
know like saying that young people yeah
we are going to reward you for your
effort right because if everybody makes
the team that you don't try hard to make
the team no no I was saying that you
even people who are trying but don't
make the cut are being encouraged to
continue participate too bad you know
that's why they have a team you either
make it or you don't make it this
country soft I hate I think this is
totally lame when we were growing up
there were cuts and you found out if
there were cuts you look on the sheet
and play sorry maybe next year try later
I mean did you ever not make something
wrong yeah I did get cut in eighth grade
basketball but I liked weaseled my way
onto the team somehow you know they say
there's a drag as a cheerleader not me
well not that I bet you could have been
if you wanted to be okay but I'm saying
there's a difference apparently between
dance and art for cheerleading and then
people who are acrobatic cheerleaders
and the question is in the weed who gets
points and who doesn't get points and
I'm saying it doesn't make a big
difference well sometimes I got it but I
know a lot about this so what happens is
sometimes you can have we used to have
at my school we had the song girls and
then we had like the cheerleaders and
the cheerleaders would do more of like
the acrobatic like the rough-and-tumble
the loud ones and then the song girls
did more of like the dance routines and
stuff like that so it was like kind of
separate and distinct so but you also
have to be in very good physical shape
to be able to do this they do go out of
the pyramid stop and you can fall and
they do flips and everything so it's not
the easiest thing it's kind of like
being a fireman you've got to be in
shape to be able to do it what it isn't
cheerleading sexist what I mean isn't
this is the whole thing so like what are
liberals doing here they're forcing
their young girls
we shouldn't have cheerleading it said I
was a when I was in second grade right
there was no girls team for soccer so my
mom convinced the coach to give me a
tryout and she said listen if she's good
enough and she's as good as you know
whatever the any of the guys playing
then put her on the team and if she's
not cutter and I made the team then my
friend Karen Hurst did and I liked that
because it taught me like rely on
yourself
practice work hard and do it and then
eventually they had a girls team do you
remember on the Brady Bunch
when Peter Brady became a sunflower
which was the Girl Scouts and then
Marcia Brady joined the Boy Scouts that
was in the early 70s Lady Bunch explains
everything references are from the early
70s I just want to say to Kimberly
Kimberly you belong at the top of the
team thank you